un échange pour rassurer le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics a répondu à
l'invitation de la députée aurore bergé
a rencontré des chefs d'entreprise de
pme et tpe illinois il y a un nom les
inquiétudes étaient fortes et le
président de la république avait pris la
décision de reporter la mise en oeuvre
du prélèvement à la source
ça nous a laissé un an pour finaliser
cette réforme fait en sorte que
techniquement les choses fonctionnent
bien et de mieux communiquer avec les
chefs d'entreprise et avec les
contribuables je pense que c'est très
important de pouvoir avoir des échanges
concrets sur les lois qui ont été votées
qui sont en application pour voir
concrètement comment elles sont mises en
deux les chefs d'entreprise présents
salue l'initiative
la réforme est bien acceptée et ils ont
eu le temps de communiquer avec leurs
salariés
ils ont cependant pu aborder certains
points de complication pour les petites
toutes les petites entreprises ont été
vus par exemple il ya un coût pour le
dirigeant qui doit s'impliquer
énormément recevoir ses salariés les
rassurer mais un coup aussi parce que le
soya surcoût pour les fiches de paye que
les cabinets d'expertise-comptable
facture
aujourd'hui lorsqu'un salarié arrive en
cours de mois enfin voilà son premier
mois de gauche on lui met une moyenne
donc il faudrait une réactivité
de là la fiscalité pour pouvoir remettre
à niveau par rapport à son salaire
justement le prélèvement olivier dussopt
s'est ensuite rendu au centre des impôts
de rambouillet les fonctionnaires lui
ont expliqué comment ils accompagnent
les administrés dans l'application de
cette réforme
alors là les souris cas pour le
changement a été fait mais je vous
explique apple ici la personne à
contacter le service des impôts via une
messagerie
son taux est modifié en quelques clics
par l'administratrice ni vraiment très
très reconnaissant à l'ensemble des
agents des services fiscaux depuis le 2
janvier le service géré son impôt à la
source sur le site internet
impots.gouv.fr très 4 millions de
visites